[Music]
next week for the second year in a row
we are taking our show down to San Diego
for comic-con very much it's gonna be
fun while we're there I'll be sitting
down with the cast of Silicon Valley
Game of Thrones Suicide Squad it is
gonna woo whoa whoa whoa whoa Conan no
spoilers what do you mean what do you
talk about well you just you just told
us exactly who your guests are gonna be
at comic-con no spoilers
yeah those those aren't spoilers those
cash shows have been announced for
several weeks now we've told a lot of
people about this okay but some of us
have been avoiding the message boards
because we like to be surprised so
please just respect that okay I won't
say anything else about the guests
anyway folks who do not want to miss
these shows it's gonna be a really
really good time Jesus man it's going to
be a really good time I mean are you
gonna leave anything up to the
imagination it's pretty obvious it's
gonna be a really good time well I
didn't know that and now it's spoiled
for me so why even watch you know okay
I'm sorry you're being a little
ridiculous all right anyway it's all
happening Wednesday July 20th through
Sunday July 24th
damn it Conan
I mean why don't you just tell us the
exact location of the shows while you're
at it okay we announce that over a year
ago we're taping this shows live from
the Spreckels theater in San Diego
that's a huge spoiler and you know and
no it is not a spoiler you know I
haven't left my apartment in over a year
because all I wanted to do was watch
your comic-con shows as they were meant
to be viewed pure untainted with no
prior knowledge about story plot or
surprise cameos now you sir and taking
that from me look I'm gonna make it up
to you right now okay is that all right
how are you gonna do that complete go
outside right now and you'll have a
special fan experience this way forget
just follow this gentleman you will have
a fan experience you'll never
what what is it no spoilers what's the
fan Express go
no spoilers yeah okay go right here okay
all right now what's gonna
[Applause]
it's a surprise
who our information about our comic-con
shows visit team koco.com slash
comic-con
[Applause]
you